ein Sommer im Krieg der zweite schon das
war ihr Badestrand von Ilja und Lisa
ihre Heimatstadt saporisha liegt am
niepro der Fluss der die Ukraine einmal
von Nord nach südteilt der Strand ist
jetzt dreimal so breit seitdem der
karovka dann zerstört wurde fehlt hier
das Wasser Russlands Krieg der seit fast
anderthalb Jahren in ihrem Land tobt hat
ihr zu Hause gezeichnet
früher war es sehr schön es gab viele
Leute die sich hier gesonnt haben und
geschwommen sind
früher bin ich hier gerne im Regen
geschwommen
Ilja und Lisa sind 14 sie sind zwei von
Millionen ukrainischer Schülerinnen und
Schüler die nun Ferien haben wie sollen
sie die genießen nach allem was war als
die Russen die Ukraine im Februar 2022
überfallen haben hat Ilja sich bei
Verwandten im Bunker versteckt
jede Stunde war wie ein neues Stück vom
Leben
wir waren glücklich dass wir am Leben
geblieben sind
viele Leute im Vorort wurden beim
Beschuss der Russen getötet
[Musik]
lisa hat die ersten kriegs-
meine Oma als ich glückliche Kinder in
Deutschland sah war ich neidisch dass
sie so ein ruhiges Leben haben dass sie
so fröhlich sind
das ist jetzt anders in ihrem Land als
Lisa wieder nach Hause kam traf sie
Kinder die ihre Eltern verloren haben
ihre Häuser das Leben hier sei nun ein
ganz anderes
am nächsten Tag Spaziergang während
raketenalarm das war ihre
lieblingsstraße
[Musik]
aber ja ich erinnere mich noch gut daran
als die Rakete hier einschlug es gab
vier Explosionen und das hat
wahrscheinlich alle aufgeweckt
eine meiner Freundinnen von der Schule
wohnte hier gegenüber aber jetzt ist sie
in Polen und wird wahrscheinlich nicht
wiederkommen
aufgrund der Explosionen nur noch von
negativen Ereignissen geprägt
deshalb macht es mir nicht mehr so viel
Freude hier entlang zu gehen
Anastasia und Victoria waren zunächst
auch in Polen mussten aber vor vier
Monaten zurückkommen den Abschluss
können Sie an Ihrer Schule nur in
Präsenz machen heute sind sie von
saporisha aufs Land gefahren um
Anastasias Oma zu besuchen das Dorf
liegt nur 20 km von der aktuellen
Frontlinie
man lebt immer mit dem Gefühl dass es
irgendwo knallt und ich treffen kann man
hat Angst ins Geschäft zu gehen es gibt
dauernd raketenalarm das ist schlimm
hier wird viel geschossen das jagt Angst
ein
das ist nicht normal
sie waren so viel glücklicher vorher nun
ist es einsamer geworden ausgelassen
sein mit Freunden das kommt selten vor
zum Glück haben sie sich
Viktoria kommt eigentlich aus militopol
noch immer ist die Stadt von Russen
besetzt sie hat mehrere
Familienmitglieder in den letzten
Monaten verloren
ich wünsche mir dass meine Tante und
mein Cousin zurückkommen
aber das geht nicht
es gibt sie nicht mehr
so vieles gibt es nicht mehr so wenig
was sie hier noch hält beide wollen die
Ukraine nach dem Abschluss verlassen
vielleicht nach Polen Victoria träumt
von Amerika
aktuell sind Sommerferien die Schulen
wieder drei Monate zu damit stellt sich
für viele Eltern die Frage wohin mit
ihren Kindern welches Angebot können Sie
ihnen schon bieten mitten im Krieg
in Botschaft bei Kiew sind die Russen zu
Kriegsbeginn eingefallen nach der
Befreiung sind viele Familien zurück
UNICEF versucht nun bei der
Kinderbetreuung zu helfen jeden Tag
kommen etwa 200 Kinder her hier können
sie spielen werden abgelenkt von Sirenen
und Ruinen trotzdem einmal wieder in
Urlaub fahren
aber jetzt ist das mehr vermiet also ist
das nicht möglich sonst würde ich
hinfahren
die Kinder hier haben viel erlebt Nastja
ist erst 11 und blieb in Botschaft
während der Besatzung der Russen zu
Kriegsbeginn
es war schwierig weil es keinen Strom
gab wir gingen nach draußen und kochten
Essen auf dem Feuer im Freien
aber dann kamen die ich will nicht sagen
wer
und es fängt an
sie fingen an zu zerstören und zu töten
dieses Kino hatten sie besetzt vergessen
was hier passiert ist wie soll das gehen
manchmal kommen Psychologen um mit den
Kindern über ihre Ängste zu sprechen
[Musik]
folterte Menschen es gab hier fast eine
Hungersnot waren
[Musik]
und es nur wenige Produkte in den
Geschäften gab
hier im Norden haben sie es geschafft
die Russen vor zu jagen im Süden bei
Ilia und Lisa ist der Feind noch immer
nur einige Kilometer entfernt sich eine
Zukunft vorzustellen wenn ihr zu Hause
immer wieder attackiert wird fällt
schwer
ich habe Träume aber wer weiß was als
nächstes passieren wird
in der Zukunft möchte ich Grafikdesigner
werden das ist mein Traum
[Musik]
ich hatte vor dem Krieg Pläne Ärztin zu
werden und Menschen zu helfen denn das
ist es was meine Familie tut aber
nachdem der Krieg begonnen hat weiß ich
nicht mehr was morgen passieren wird ob
ich lebe oder nicht
mir ist für sie weitergeht wissen sie
nicht leben oder nicht das ist jetzt
ihre Kindheit das sind die Teenagerjahre
im Krieg